[Music]  our emotion said mm-hmm the white  minority is an enemy we must never talk  to them but our brain said if you don't  talk to this man your country will go up  in flames and for many years to come  this country would be engulfed in rivers  of blood so we had to reconcile that  conflict and I want talking to the enemy  was the result of the domination of the  brain  all right emotions you just watched two  amazing clips from Nelson Mandela take  the next three minutes and sit quietly  to think about how you can apply them to  your business and your life believe  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]